a Zelda game without bosses is like a
soda vending machine that only sells
club soda you know that flavorless
sparkling water which is gross I hate
drinking that stuff I'd much rather have
a Fanta or a Sprite or a Diet Coke but
speaking of water for the next game on
my lore of the boss's list we're going
to the endless oceans of the Legend of
Zelda The Wind Waker and I'll be honest
on my top 10 Zelda games list Wind Waker
is tied with Twilight Princess for
second place so personally I'm really
excited to get into this one and I hope
you are too if you're interested in the
boss lore of other Zelda games check out
the playlist in the description below
but for now prepare to get wet and
spoiler alert obviously the simplest way
to go about explaining wind waker's many
bosses and minibosses would be to just
go in order of the game's dungeon so
we're gonna do just that starting with
the very first dungeon in the game
dragon Roost Cavern located on Dragon
Roost Isle the very first miniboss you
face is a moblin and actually
technically you face up a goblin as a
minibus before the model and way back in
the Forsaken Fortress both of these
enemies are just regular monsters
stemming from High Roll which may or may
not have originated entirely from
demise's demonic power many years ago
depending on what you believe but in the
Wind Waker the only thing that really
needs explaining is how they're here and
by here I mean up here as in on the
surface of the ocean and not down in
Hyrule where they came from fortunately
for us the answer is rather simple
Ganondorf himself brought these monsters
up from Deep beneath the waves when he
began to execute his plan of regaining
the pieces of the Triforce having it
ripped from his clutches All Those Years
Ago by the hero of time in Princess
Zelda but more on ganondorf's story
later in the video the boss of dragon
Roost Cavern is a giant totally not
nightmare inducing arachnid centipede
Lava Monster insect thing known as Goma
now according to a direct quote from the
wind waker's great Deku Tree the
monsters that stir in the Forbidden
Woods are there because of ganondorf's
return and the same reasoning can
probably be used to blanket explain a
lot of the monsters appearances in the
game including the likes of Goma herself
while that may seem like an adequate
explanation I wouldn't make these videos
if I didn't think I could bring
something else to the table and in this
case I'd like to mention that I think
what Ganondorf did specifically is he
simply introduced one of the magtail
monsters into the cavern at some point
which then grew into Goma which then
began to lay eggs and give birth to
other magtails and spread them
throughout the dungeon I mean Gomer
really does seem like a big version of
the smaller magtail monster with being
centipede-like immune to Lava having a
single eye and giant pincers and all
that who knows maybe there even would
have been several gomas if link hadn't
obliterated these ones next up we have
the formerly mentioned Forbidden Woods
located right next to the rather
friendly and not Forbidden Forest Haven
now I'm not gonna go super in depth into
explaining the dungeon itself and why
it's separate from the Forest Haven
proper and why I think it very closely
resembles the Forest Haven because I'm
probably gonna start up a series on the
lore of the dungeons here pretty soon so
I'm gonna skip straight to the bosses
the mini boss of the dungeon is once
again an insect monster known as mafula
which comes in two versions winged and
non-winged though I personally assume
that the winged version is the fully
mature version just like all the other
mini boss in the game Mafia itself is
not very one of a kind in fact there are
many of them in the game across various
little caves and such and they actually
make appearances in other Zelda games
such as a link to the past where they
appear in the Skull Woods which is the
Dark World variant of the Lost Woods
coincidence I think not what mafules are
is a very dangerous species of mutant
moth that can spurt out little babies
called morphs that are little one-eyed
spiky balls that love to latch onto
moving organisms like link and just kind
of sit there slowing you down they don't
want to eat you or anything they just
invade your personal space which is rude
the morphs themselves are present all
over the place in the Forbidden Woods
which leads me to believe that Ganondorf
did a very similar thing here like he
did with the magtails in Dragon Roost
Cavern and just released an infestation
of moreths to take over the place lots
of fun the main boss of the Forbidden
Woods is a bit more abstract to explain
in that it's a living killer plant known
as the kale demos and seeing as the
theme of the entire dungeon is overgrown
killer nature it makes sense to me that
the kalai demos would be an overgrown
more deadly version of a bokobaba of
which there are several present here in
the Forbidden Woods and even on the
Forest Haven it's so massive that it
uses its roots as weapons and Vines to
literally detach from the ground and
theoretically be able to move all around
the place if it wanted to heck it could
probably vacation on Windfall Island as
far as what its name means it's unsure
since the original Japanese name for the
kale demos is Kare demos so there really
aren't any hints there but in the
Spanish version of the game its name is
villopendulia which if translated in
Latin means to blaspheme or to revile or
if translated in Corsican means
vilification which is kind of the same
thing following up on this name meaning
it could be interpreted that it relates
to the Forbidden Woods directly since
the Forbidden Woods itself is more than
likely the corrupted version of the old
Lost Woods but more on that in the
probable upcoming dungeon video the
kalei demos can also be killed
immediately with the forest water from
the Deku Tree so the corruption Theory
kind of makes sense as far as what led
to this monster plant becoming the
monster plant it can be assumed that it
was due to the same curse place upon the
Woods by Ganondorf that led to all the
overgrown Vines around the place and of
course the wonderful Norths and Mafia
moving on next up we have the bosses
from the Tower of the Gods which
alternatively actually is not an area
that was corrupted or infested with evil
or anything of the sort actually quite
the opposite the Tower of the Gods and
its enemies within were all created by
certain people in the past you know kind
of like all the sheikah shrines in
breath of the wild the minibus of the
tower is the very first Dark Knight you
face in the game and the reason why I
say the first Dark Knight is because
there are many many dark nuts in other
locations throughout this game this one
specifically however is if it's special
because it's located within the mostly
untouched Tower of the Gods thus giving
even more Credence to an older theory of
mind about the dark notes and their
literal possible blood relations to link
which I will link in the description
below if you're interested in a much
deeper dive for the time being however
it's my interpretation that the dark
notes are actually corrupted old Knights
of Hyrule after all every single one of
them in the Wind Waker wears a knight's
Crest which has pretty obvious Loft
wings symbolism on it and as a reminder
Loft wings are the symbol of the Hylian
royal family and I highly doubt that
every single one of the dark notes would
be able to steal a knight's Crest I
believe this particular dark note was
placed here to test the hero like all
the other various enemies and mechanisms
in the Tower of the Gods but that it was
tainted by ganondorf's Magic due to
other reasons that I go into in the
aforementioned video the boss of the
dungeon is a grand combat construct that
snorts arrows known as godan the great
Arbiter godan's figurine describes it as
a construct that was placed there
directly by the gods themselves in order
to test the hero's combat Pro s and this
is pretty much entirely accurate
actually it is a tester and it's titled
the great Arbiter literally means the
great decider as in it decides whether
or not the hero is worthy it's pretty
cut and dry and the only question
remaining is whether or not the gods
themselves actually literally crafted
godan with their own hands or if they
test certain other people to do so in
their stead personally my money's on the
sheikah I mean come on with all the eye
symbolism everywhere the Grand and
technology the servitude to the gods and
the neon blue energy yeah it all seems
to fit the criteria moving on the next
dungeon that link has to fight through
is actually a return to the Forsaken
Fortress now that he's descended down to
Old Hyrule and retrieve the master sword
from its secret chamber of the sages the
first boss that link faces is the mini
boss known as Phantom Ganon and this
should be a familiar enemy for many fans
of the series because Phantom Ganon made
his debut in the previous game in the
timeline Ocarina of Time where in that
game Phantom Ganon is heavily implied to
be a separate living demonic being
created by Ganondorf via his dark powers
in order to fight Link after which he
gets banished to the quote gap between
Dimensions which probably means
nothingness in a spooky Cosmic
lovecraftian kind of way the Phantom
ganons In The Wind Waker are largely the
same they are Phantom versions of
Ganondorf himself that he sends out to
try to commit murder upon link they even
use the same Dead Man's volley move set
to attack link one thing you might be
wondering though is why did Ganondorf
not send out a phantom Ganon or two to
protect the first second Fortress the
first time around and this is actually
because of Link see as Ganondorf himself
proves to us when link drew the master
sword it actually released the seal on
ganondorf's power previously I guess he
was just running on fumes but with his
true Powers restored he's able to
construct an unlimited number of these
Phantoms to fight against link and by
the way if you're interested in why the
master sword was able to seal
ganondorf's power and also all of the
kingdom of Hyrule in stasis and why it
looks so different and why it's
positioned somewhere completely
different to its last location in
Ocarina of Time check out this Theory I
did on the possibility of a second
master sword you're gonna love it it's
really neat actually and one last thing
I'll mention about the Phantom ganons in
Wind Waker is that their swords actually
Bear an inscription on the blade the
inscription reads zubora gabora when
read in Hylian which are the names of
the two smithies in the Mountain Village
in Majora's Mask yeah there's probably a
theory or 12 there but we don't have
time for that so anyway the actual Boss
Of The Forsaken Fortress this time
around is that big gnarly nasty giant
child kidnap bird known as the Monstrous
helmerok King the bird looks very very
similar to the car Crux in the game in
fact they have nearly identical feather
patterns on their bodies and wings
nearly identical feet and the helm
Rock's tail looks like a more grander
and duplicated version of the cargurox
this pretty heavily implies that the
helmarak is an overgrown version of a
carderock maybe this is what happens
when you actually eat all of your
veggies growing up I guess Mom was on to
something now it is possible that the
Helmer rock is so massive due to
ganondorf's influence or power or
corruption but I personally find that a
bit difficult to believe since his
powers were much weaker prior to Link's
removal of the master sword meaning the
greater chance is that the helmerok is
really just a big cargo Rock I also
wanted to mention that it shares both a
name and an extremely similar fight to
the helmosaur king from A Link to the
Past both of which actually share the
same name in Japanese
must use a mighty Hammer to break both
of their helmets before being able to
unleash punishment on their faces and
the helmishor king is also just a bigger
version of smaller helmets source which
is yet another similarity to the Helmer
Rock King helmosaurs make other
appearances in the child timeline in the
Fallen timeline but never do pop up in
the adult timeline perhaps this means
that the Wind Waker kargorock species is
the evolution of the helmosaur species
which would fit into wind waker's
evolved Hyrule theme with other races
and monsters and cargo rocks and
Twilight Princess are very lizard-like
and since Twilight Princess takes place
sooner after Ocarina of Time that wind
waker does that could mean that these
cargo rocks are in their middle step on
their way to evolving into the ones we
see in the Wind Waker but I digress I
didn't really mean to go into cargox as
much but there you go the helmerok king
explained the next dungeon that the
Brave Young green boy must Venture
through is the Earth Temple the first
boss of which is a stealthos now anyone
who knows the Legend of Zelda knows
about stalfo's enemies simply put
estafos is a demonically resurrected
pile of bones could be anyone's bones
could be a humans or a lizalfos or a
bakoblins or yours or mine that would be
gross but the stealthos is in Wind
wakers share explanations with all
stealthos enemies throughout the entire
franchise franchise which is that they
are resurrected baddies that arise via
the power of evil which stems from
Ganondorf which stems from demise the
main boss of the Earth Temple is jalhala
which is a large Poe made of a
conglomerate of smaller pose if you
watched my previous bossler video on
Twilight Princess you'll probably recall
that I stated that I believed that the
death sword from that game is also a
conglomeration of dead Spirits or Poes
in this case you can literally watch as
multiple pose gather into the mask of
JAL Hall to form its giant bod which
pretty much immediately explains
everything well almost everything see
jalhala is actually very old ancient
even it was actually the being
responsible for murdering the previous
Sage of Earth named laruto medley's
predecessor and also the only Zora you
see in the game when you combine this
with the fact that it once again appears
as a mini boss alongside Goma the Kali
demos and mulguera in ganon's Castle it
can be inferred that this means that it
or more specifically the mask that forms
its big bod was created by Ganondorf
perhaps he once again just released a
bunch of pose in The Mask itself into
the Earth Temple in order to corrupt it
like he's done several times before In
This Very video as a reminder pose in
this franchise are specifically
ill-spirited spirits that roam the land
of the living because they have
unfinished business and are filled with
negativity and thoughts of violence
combine a bunch of them into a big Poe
and you get jalhala the second to last
dungeon in the game is the wind Temple
the mini boss of the temple is a wizrow
which again is not a unique enemy but it
kind of is because it wears red and it's
also much more powerful than the other
lesser whiz Road and can even summon
other lesser Wiz robes to fight for it
which is kind of meta now as I explained
in the Majora's Mask boss lore video wiz
robes are recurring enemies across the
Zelda franchise stemming from the
original game of a variable power level
sometimes they're normal enemies that
you can fight a bunch of at a time other
times like in Majora's Mask or Wind
Waker they're powerful enough to Merit
miniboss battles all by themselves
another variable about them is their
appearance which shifts from looking
like a human witch to grew from
Despicable Me to an anthropomorphic
toucan in this game I personally believe
that all Wiz robes are simply members of
a race of individuals located somewhere
in Hyrule that Masters dark magic and
either do to that Mastery or due to
their own personal reasons decides to
serve the forces of Darkness who in this
case is Ganondorf what's most intriguing
about their appearance in Wind Waker is
their bird-like physical features such
as their toucan-like beaks or their
sleeves that look like wings or the fact
that they can hover in the air and fly
given that this was also the game that
introduced us to the Rito who are the
race of bird people that evolved from
the Zora it's only natural for people to
wonder about whether or not the whiz
robes are members of the Rito as well
which could very well be the case
personally though I tend to think a bit
more simplistically to me it just seems
like the Wiz robes might have used their
magic and turned themselves into these
bird-like forms in order to achieve
flight which they can do in this game as
opposed to their earlier iterations
which could only teleport around the
place but it's true given their bird
characteristics which is conveniently in
the same game that introduced us to the
Rito they could be Wiz robes that stem
from the Rito race there's no evidence
to prove definitively one way or the
other and the retail also pretty much
all have long sleeve leaves that turn
into Wings also there are lesser Wizz
robes that appear in the Tower of the
Gods as I mentioned earlier all of the
mechanisms and constructs within the
Tower of the Gods were constructed by
the will of the Gods and for the
purposes of testing link so how then
could Wiz robes be located inside well
it's evident that at least some of
ganon's power was able to enter the
tower since there are keys and Bubbles
and chuchus and lesser wizrobes in a
crazed Darkness located within so I
suppose it's possible that Ganondorf was
able to sneak in a couple monsters I'm
not sure when he would have been able to
do this but that's neither here nor
there the boss of the wooden Temple is a
giant flying sand monster known as
mogera and just like jalhala in the
Earth Temple moguera is assumedly
responsible for the death of the wind
Sage named Fado macar's predecessor and
the only Kokiri you see in the game and
just to follow suit with the whole big
monster with small versions of big
monster Vibes that the entire game has
been giving off this whole time mulgaria
can also release its little babies to
attack link affectionately referred to
as mogera larvae in The Legend of Zelda
series it seems that certain words or
phrases of words are often used to refer
to that type of enemy for instance a
baba is always a plant a blin is always
a humanoid usually pig-like monster a
stall is always an undead enemy a foes
is a nightlike enemy a rock is a bird
and a mole is a sand or worm-like
monster in this manner the mulgaria
shares its sand swimming capabilities
with that of the molduga of breath of
the wild where the mole dorms from
several other games and due to its
reappearance in ganon's Tower and Fado
directly saying that he was attacked by
Ganondorf and the encyclopedia stating
that ganon's minions attack the temples
it can be assumed that moguera
originated from you guessed it Ganondorf
himself seriously it's like after his
defeat at the end of Ocarina of Time he
just thought to himself you know what I
should do this time around in order to
guarantee me a win insects giant insects
but speaking of the big man himself it's
finally his time to shine so without
further Ado let's talk about the man the
myth the undying Legend Ganondorf
dragmire ganon's Tower is the final
dungeon in the game and as such Ganon
himself is the final boss both of them
in fact see the first time you and
counter Ganondorf it's not actually
Ganondorf but is rather a Ganon now for
a much more in-depth explanation as to
what I believe Ganon is as opposed to
Ganondorf and to not be too redundant in
these videos check out the breath of the
Wild bossler video where I went into
much more detail explaining it in a
nutshell though I personally believe
that Ganondorf will transform into a
Ganon when Ganondorf is infused with a
great power source with vegan as in the
original anthropomorphic pig-like
monster Ganon being ganondorf's Triforce
of power transformation however if you
recall at this point in the timeline
that Ganon is dead thanks to the hero of
time and this is why that Ganon does not
make an appearance in Wind Waker it's
also why Ganondorf himself does not
physically transform into a Ganon in
this game even though it kind of looks
like he does in reality though that's
just puppet Ganon who's being controlled
by Ganondorf who is awaiting link above
puppet ganon's chamber on top of the
tower my take on the matter and of
course you're always welcome to believe
whichever take you want is that puppet
Ganon is the big version if you will of
the Phantom ganons located elsewhere in
the game game just you know to follow
suit with the aforementioned small
version and big version of monsters that
this game is so fond of using I believe
that the puppet Ganon is essentially the
most powerful version of phantom Ganon
that Ganondorf could create which again
also explains why Ganondorf himself does
not transform into puppet Ganon unlike
in Ocarina of Time and Twilight Princess
when he did literally transform into the
Triforce powered Ganon and the
twilight-powered dark Beast Ganon anyway
once link kills puppet Ganon with arrows
of light he then ascends to face
Ganondorf himself who has had his
Triforce of power this entire time
because he still retained it following
his ceiling away at the end of Ocarina
of Time huge props to Nintendo by the
way for leaving us with this
foreshadowing Cliffhanger way back in
1998. to be honest wind waker's version
of Ganondorf has got to be one of my
favorites if not my favorite because
this is a Ganondorf who learned patience
he learned how to wait and buyed his
time to build up scraps of power at
first and eventually break out of the
seal that he was placed in so many years
ago he's more solemn and mature than any
of his other iterations and does not
necessarily wish to bring unnecessary
Siri home to Link and Zelda he even goes
so far as to try to reassure link by
saying do not fear I will not kill you
and he says that he wishes to sever that
which binds them together so that he
would not have to keep fighting literal
children every few centuries he also
gives more insight into the reasoning
behind his usurper actions in Ocarina of
Time in Twilight Princess the reason why
he so badly craves hyrule's Throne is
because he's jealous Covetous the Gerudo
desert his home is a harsh environment
that few species can survive in the day
it's blisteringly hot and in the night
it's bone-chillingly frigid something
that we can see firsthand in breath of
the wild as the king of the Garuda women
who somehow lived in the desert he
wanted better for them he wanted the
beautiful landscapes and temperate
climates and bountiful fields that the
Winds of Hyrule brought to the people of
Hyrule and thus he decided to conquer
the royal family and try to take it by
force but now that Hyrule is all but
dead and his people are gone we're left
with one final question why why is
Ganondorf still striving so hard to
obtain the Triforce so long after
everyone is vanished and the world has
moved on well that's actually the entire
Point have you ever felt nostalgic
Ganondorf did he never wanted to hurt
people at least not initially all he
ever wanted was Hyrule he had heard the
legends of an all-powerful Relic that
could Grant the wishes of its user and
he always wanted to use that wish to
obtain Hyrule for himself and his people
but as close as he came to the Triforce
he never got to make that wish so here
after countless years have gone by and
the world has moved on from the Old
Kingdom beneath the waves Ganondorf
never forgot about that land that he
loved Hyrule and as he finally pieced to
the Triforce together again he reached
his hand into the sky and cried out to
the gods above to resurrect Hyrule from
its watery Slumber and give it to him
but just before he touches the
omnipotent Relic daphnis na Hansen
Hyrule himself the last king of Hyrule
Touches at first and instead wishes for
the opposite that the world would
finally forget about the sins of the
Kingdom the crimes of the Gerudo and the
entire land of Hyrule itself be drowned
forever in Ganondorf along with it and
after all this time as the ocean begins
to literally crash in over their heads
with a great downpour of rain Ganondorf
cannot help but laugh in his utter
bitter defeat and it's at this point
that he lets his old angry self shine
through again and he decides to try to
kill link Zelda and the King but is once
again defeated for the Last Time by The
Duo of hylia's descendant and her chosen
hero the last thing Ganondorf feels
before entering the gap between
Dimensions himself is the Blissful wind
of the beautiful kingdom of Hyrule and
that is the end of the wind waker's
bosses did you learn something new did I
miss something which game do you want to
be covered next let me know in the
comments below and thank you so very
much for watching please consider
leaving a like on the video If you
enjoyed it and subscribe if you haven't
already because seriously we do good
stuff here stick around you can always
leave later huge thanks as always to my
Bandit crew who are the reason I keep
going with the channel say hello to link
one underscore 87 underscore JV and John
G who both recently joined in the ranks
of my mighty Bandits if you're
interested in helping out please feel
free to check out the many different
methods in the description below that's
all I've got for this one so be sure to
follow me on my socials and I'll see you
next time this is Bandit signing out
peace
[Music]